You obviously accomplished a lot before
you made mindfulness part of your life
more than most people accomplish in
their lives.
So do you think that your clarity of
thinking has changed in the last eight
years?
Um,
and is it,
isn't mindfulness necessary for clear
thought or could you have it without it
as you did for so many years before?
Unquestionably,
mindfulness enhances,
as you've said in your book and our
clarity of thought.
Unquestionably,
both anecdotally and scientifically,
we can.
We can prove that point.
One of the main reasons is because by
allowing us to be in the moment,
it means we don't stay with what just
happened and that's one of the reasons
that Phil Jackson now,
the coach of the Knicks has given for
making mindfulness mandatory as part of
the next training,
which I love.
I love having a lead athletes
incorporating mindfulness into their
training.
And the reason Phil Jackson gave is that
he said,
you're always going to make mistakes.
You know the field learning the court.
The question is,
can you then move on and be fully
present?
Otherwise,
you're going to carry that mistake with
you and your actions and your decisions
are going to be impaired because of
that.
Well,
the same applies to life.
If I'm still smarting over something
that happened that I'm not happy with
WHO and when come when the moment comes
from me to make another decision or
react to something new,
it's going to affect that particular
moments decision.
Yeah.
It's interesting that you mentioned
professional athletes.
One of the things that strikes me about
the mindfulness research,
and you mentioned a lot of this in your
book,
is just how broadly it's been adapted.
I mean it's not just athletes.
We have the military,
different studies with mindfulness.
You have hedge fund managers like Ray
Daleo saying that that's part of their
success.
All of these people clearly have used it
after they reach a certain elite point
in their career and then they use
mindfulness to homeless,
transcend,
you know,
to get a step further,
to be the athlete who's not just a great
athlete,
but who can overcome the problems in the
moment.
Do you feel like there needs to be some
work that has to happen beforehand?
Not at all.
And I think with athletes,
definitely we see them integrating
mindfulness meditation training into
their coaching right away.
Uh,
I think the reason why we have so many
successful people who have accomplished
a lot,
who's burned out along the way and have
not exactly lived very mindfully is
because our culture is drenched in the
delusion that,
uh,
the only way to really succeed is to
burn out.
I'm standing when you go back read,
um,
Thomas Edison inventing,
inventing the electric bulb and talking
about how sleep is something to be
completely contemptuous towards,
uh,
the whole Macho idealization of sleep
deprivation and burnout.
That very,
very deeply embedded in our culture,
in our language.
You know,
we congratulate people for working 24
slash seven.
We congratulate people for being always
on.
And so we have a lot of work to do to
unravel that.
And I think that a lot of people who
have succeeded,
I have done so despite the father,
the burned out along the way,
not because of it and I have included in
the book a lot of people who are sort of
iconic in our culture,
like Steve Jobs saying that he came with
his best ideas that lead to the most
iconic apple products after zen
meditation.
And he describes it very well,
saying this was when he could hear more
subtle things.
You know,
the idea that gender,
you're multitasking,
you are more efficient,
is a complete illusion.
And yet so many of us believe that
that's why you walk down the streets of
New York and you see so many people who
can't walk without being on the phone or
worse walking and texting.
And I was one of these people.
I remember when I stopped doing that,
I started noticing things that I had
completely missed.
Like I remember going down the street
where I live in her and seeing this
beautiful building and telling a friend,
this is such a beautiful building.
And I said,
when did it go off?
She said 80 90,
and I wonder what else have I missed.